(fast percussion music)
- There's a whole world beneath the city,
visited by over four
million people each day.
This urine scented metropolis is
not only home to pizza stealing rats,
but one of the most diverse music
scenes in the United States.
(upbeat piano music)
(collective singing)
Artists come from all over the
world to play on the stage.
When you turn a corner or exit a train,
you never know what kinds of
sounds you'll be met with.
(R&B music)
Sometimes it's classical violin.
(slow violin music)
Sometimes it's EDM violin.
(fast violin music)
So we're here in New York City,
we're about to run around and interview
a bunch of street performers
and seasoned buskers.
I'm excited because I've never
performed on the street before.
Even though I've been performing and
playing the piano for about 20 years now.
So we'll see what happens,
and maybe later on I will get
a chance at busking myself.
- [DeeWho] Good day ladies and gentlemen.
My name is DeeWho and I'm
here with a song for you.
(blues music)
- [Nahre] Street performance,
often called busking,
goes back to ancient times.
As author Patricia J. Campbell puts it,
"There have been street
performers at least
"as long as there have been streets."
♪ Oh I said all the wrong things ♪
♪ Oh I stood my ground ♪
- Just day to day, going
through being on the train,
walking through the city, my
wish is always to be anonymous.
But this is sort of the opposite of that.
You're putting yourself out there,
and I think it's really brave.
♪ You were ignoring all the signs ♪
♪ You took my hand and you set me down ♪
- [Nahre] There's a little bit of tension
in the train that's also
good for performing.
But it's like a different feeling.
- Like the reason I think
I'm able to do this,
is because I come and I
bring a sincere energy.
- [Nahre] And how long
have you been doing this?
- Done this actually as
my, basically my day job,
for like the last five years.
I make better money doing this
than I certainly did waiting tables.
And definitely than I did doing a
lot of other jobs that I only did
for no reason other than money.
So I mean hell, I was
doing this for free anyway.
♪ Ohhh ♪
(clapping)
- I moved to New York City,
to pursue my dream of music.
But I was nannying part time,
I love kids and I was like
this is a good part time job
that'll allow me to, to still like,
go to open mics and like, do music.
And I would see people busking and I
always just thought it
was like so courageous.
And I would see like amazing buskers where
I was just like wow.
Like they're so talented and
they were so, like, care free.
And I was just like I
wish I had those guts.
♪ Light it up ♪
♪ YOLO is what I believe in ♪
♪ Fight it up ♪
Finally I was like, let me try it,
worked up the nerve and I did it.
And I was making more than I was nannying.
So since then I just, I started busking.
♪ As we light it up ♪
(upbeat electronic music)
- [Nahre] Here in New York City
there's a complicated
legal history with busking.
(upbeat violin music)
And over the last
century the city has gone
back and forth on whether or
not it's allowed or banned.
During the great depression,
busking became a popular
way to make money.
That is until Mayor Fiorello
LaGuardia outlawed it in 1936,
calling the street performers beggars.
(upbeat violin music)
The ban continued all the way to 1970,
when poet Allen Ginsberg,
challenged the ban as
unconstitutional and won.
Busking is protected as a form of free
speech in the U.S.
Meaning it can't be prohibited
in areas where other
forms of free speech are not prohibited.
But even though busking is
now legal in the subways,
that hasn't stopped the
police from arresting buskers.
- [Man] You can't do that.
- [Yut] Cops are so annoying.
- Are they?
- Yeah, even I, even I have the permit,
they come up to me sometimes.
It's like it's to loud,
or it's just annoying.
- It was really a struggle,
if you weren't a sponsored musician,
if you weren't a Music
Under New York Musician,
you go through that process.
Then yeah it was tough.
(upbeat violin music)
♪ I'm trying so hard ♪
♪ To get by ♪
- [Nahre] In 1985 the MTA created
a program called Music Under New York,
that gives artists a special
permit to perform in the subways.
For some, this permit is great,
because it allows you to get priority
at popular locations, and
protection from law enforcement.
- [Nahre] Can you tell us
a little bit about MUNY?
- Yes.
So Music Under New York is a program
that was created for people
like myself and other
talented performers through out the city,
to be able to legally
perform in the subway.
And not, you know, get in
trouble with the police.
And so there are
regulations, like you know,
spaces, and places you can
do it and things like that.
The audition it takes, once a year,
about they audition about
maybe 300 people this year.
And out of 300 they chose me
as one of the people for this,
to get into the front round.
- [Nahre] Admittance into the program
is through one audition held every year.
And from the over 300 musical
acts that applied in 2018,
only 28 were admitted.
This had led many musicians
to criticize the MTA for
virtually controlling
who can and who can't
perform in the subway systems.
♪ Say it yeah ♪
♪ I'm trying so hard ♪
- MUNY is, is uh, maybe
necessary in some ways
I suppose if you really
want to not break the law
technically playing with amplification.
I kind of enjoy breaking
the law in small ways.
(laughs)
Maybe you could cut that out.
- [Nahre] No, I mean I
think that's awesome.
♪ It starts with today ♪
♪ No more holdin' me ♪
♪ I'm livin' my life ♪
♪ No one checks over me ♪
♪ It starts with today ♪
♪ No more holdin' me ♪
- [Nahre] The good news
is that in recent years,
the police have begun to
loosen up on arresting buskers.
This has hopefully
created a more fair space,
where both MUNY artists and independent
artists can share their
talents with the public.
♪ I've been a liar ♪
♪ I've been a thief ♪
♪ I've done stuff you wouldn't believe ♪
- Any noticeable differences between when
you first started performing
on the streets versus now?
- Yes, absolutely.
We've had mayoral changes.
So ever since that leadership changed,
I've noticed the law enforcement
really loosen up on
busting buskers' chops.
So to speak
(upbeat piano music)
- What motivates you to come out here
even on cold days like this?
- It's soul food for me.
It's necessary, for my
health and well-being, yeah.
♪ We all grow up ♪
♪ Oh ♪
- [Nahre] I like the comparison
of busking to soul food,
because it's the passion
for music that keeps these
artists coming back to perform.
Busking isn't easy and even
though there are many rewards,
there are just as many challenges.
(singing in foreign language)
- [Nahre] What are some
challenging things about busking?
- Every now and then
I get a kind of a grinch like person.
(laughs)
- How do you deal with that?
- I don't.
- You don't.
- I just (laughs).
- I like that.
- People don't seem to care anymore,
everybody has headphones on,
or they're looking at their iPhone.
- You know you're just talking at walls.
And a lot of people do
talk at walls in this city.
A lot of people totally talk at walls.
A lot of people are walls to be talked at.
(singing in foreign language)
- The most challenging
thing about busking,
is getting things here.
- [Nahre] Lugging--
- Lugging my stuff, yeah lugging my stuff.
- Sound, no electricity.
- Playing with gloves on
underneath a grate you know,
and the cold air is just
like blasting down on you.
Getting those sympathy tips.
- At one point I was singing and people
were gathering and you know,
applauding me, and really getting into it,
and singing along and putting
money in my little basket.
And this one person was
like why are you singing?
- [Nahre] Oh no!
- Why do you have it blah blah blah blah,
you know you sound
terrible blah blah blah.
And I was like, kay.
I just, I didn't really
react but she kept going.
And the more she kept saying crazy stuff,
the more people would just
put money in my basket.
So I was hoping she would keep going.
(slow acoustic guitar music)
- [Nahre] I also think that busking
provides a unique space to experiment.
What I mean by that is when
you perform at a concert,
the audience is there to see you,
and most likely came to hear music.
However when you're busking,
you're performing for
people in their space,
and they can choose to ignore
you or stop and listen.
- You are imposing on people by being,
it's a public space, and I mean,
you fart on the train
you're imposing on people.
You know, sorry I farted on your world.
But (laughing) it's my
idea of a nice smell.
You know?
(laughing)
- Wait what?
Okay.
(laughing)
♪ To let my light shine yeah ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
- Do you feel like it's easier to connect
with people while you're busking versus,
performing on a different
stage or a different venue?
- I think because the subway allows you
to interact with anyone and everyone,
and anyone and everyone can listen.
It gives you a wider platform to
engage with a wider audience,
as opposed to someone
that can't afford to pay,
or who's able to pay to go to a show,
or whatever it is you know.
♪ They say pray pray pray pray ♪
♪ Oh how you worship ♪
♪ I wish I could love what you see ♪
- I started busking because,
I've known since I was little
that I wanted to be a singer.
But as I got older and I was auditioning
and performing more,
I was suffering from really
bad performance anxiety.
- Okay.
- So much so that it actually
was getting in my way,
and I was losing like the joy
that I had found in singing.
So that's when I decided
to do something bold
and like kind of like,
push my comfort zone as best as I could.
And the thing I thought of
was singing in the subway.
- I deal with a lot of stage fright.
- [Emma] Yeah.
- And I have all my life.
- But anytime I remember that it's about
something that's not within but--
- [Emma] Right.
- Outside with the audience.
- Right.
- It usually gets better.
♪ I will learn ♪
♪ To let my light shine ♪
- I have a question
personally about busking,
and playing outside
publicly on the keyboard.
I'm going to try later
on today, with my friend.
Do you have any tips for someone who
is completely new to busking?
- Absolutely.
- And someone who's rather shy,
in terms of doing stuff in public.
- I do, because I was there.
- Okay.
- And actually I've come a long way,
from when I started busking.
It took me at least
five years to figure out
that you have to interact
with the audience.
Hey if you guys have any requests,
please write them on a fifty dollar bill.
You know, stuff that gets people laughing.
I mean you don't have to.
You can all be in your instrument.
But...
It's a, it's a huge difference.
I see it in the tips.
- [Nahre] And I have a question about
your Venmo sign.
- [Emma] Yes.
- A lot of people don't
carry cash anymore.
- Right.
One day in the middle of a set, you know,
a girl came up to me and she was like,
oh do you have Venmo?
And I was like no.
And she was like, oh well I
really like what you're doing,
and I wanna give you a tip
but I don't have any cash,
so you should like get a Venmo.
And I was like that is a fabulous idea.
I should get a Venmo.
- [Nahre] I met up with my friend
Dotan at his workspace in SOHO.
He's performed all over the
world with his upright piano,
in unexpected places like a
subway car and the Eiffel Tower.
- Hi my name is Dotan
and today we're gonna be,
we're playing music in
the subway and it's fun.
- But you've done this before right?
- Oh yeah.
- This is my first time.
- So I used to, I used to walk around and,
I'm doing such a bad job at this.
I'm sorry!
(laughing)
- We just set up and we're going
to busk for about 20 to 30
minutes and see what happens.
The goal is to make five bucks.
(laughing)
- Five.
- That's a, that's a good goal.
Oh there you go, that's the one.
(slow electronic music)
- I'll do this.
And then you solo over it.
(slow electronic music)
- Nice.
(slow piano music)
(laughing)
- Give us money, we need money.
- I think we need to up the energy.
- I mean part of it's eye contact maybe.
I mean that looks good to me,
in terms of engagement.
We gotta be louder.
(upbeat electronic music)
- Yeah, keep the energy out here.
- And a Merry Christmas.
How you doing?
Thank you.
- [Nahre] The buskers that we
met this week made it look easy.
But in the end we made just two dollars.
Here in New York,
street performers went
from being called beggars,
to an important part of
the subway experience,
and vital to the city's music culture.
- [Yut] busking used
to be looked down upon,
they're like oh those homeless.
But now in this time I think people
see busking as oh wow
he's doing an art form.
And because buskers in
New York are amazing.
- I think it's important
to understand that
what you are doing as a busker is,
you are giving positive energy
to everyone that hears you.
And sometimes you may uplift someone from
a very dark or negative place.
- Nobody might tip you.
It can get discouraging for sure.
But that's an indication that you're
not doing it for the right reasons.
- If one day I was to
look back at these years
as the best years of my life,
I'm okay with that, I'd be okay with that.
(slow electronic music)